republicans are also in a fl fight to
hang on to the u.s
senate with some races that were not
supposed to be tight
getting tighter and some considered to
be fairly easy pickups
not looking as easy this week chief
congressional correspondent mike emanuel
has that part of the story tonight
this was supposed to be an easier year
for republicans running for the senate
with a number of democrats and
conservative states
on the ballot but at this stage things
are too close for the gop's comfort
a prime example is texas senator ted
cruz
we got a fight on our hands the extreme
left
they're angry they're energized
and they are filled with hatred his
opponent congressman beto o'rourke
is drawing big dollars and big crowds
it's about the future of this country
the big things we want to do going from
the least insured state in the country
to the one that leads on universal
health care
real clear politics lists eight other
races as toss-ups
arizona indiana montana missouri
florida tennessee nevada and north
dakota
a two-seat swing would put the democrats
in the majority
the tight polls in many of these senate
races have democrats feeling upbeat
even as some in red states carefully
navigate the trump factor
hoosiers want a senator who works for
them
that i'll work with any president but i
don't work for
any president i work for the people of
indiana democratic strategists note
their incumbent candidates
must deliver north dakota missouri and
florida
three very close very tough fights and
very tough states
for three members of the senate two of
whom at least had
won during obama's last election where
they had the benefit of him at the top
of the ticket
both sides are closely watching texas
and tennessee democratic leader chuck
schumer has said
his party's path to the majority runs
through those two states sources close
to majority leader mitch mcconnell
acknowledge a tough environment
but say they cannot see losing the
senate majority
brett mike thanks